The top that's like at the end of the F uh, uh,
uh, uh, what's that Matthew McConaughey movie in court,
where you got big and famous for it, time to kill. Is that what it was?
And he's just like going on and on,
and then your daughter was raped and then she was killed and then she was beat
up. And then now imagine now,
imagine she was wide at the end and you were just like, Oh man, chilling.
That's what it was for me when I did that.
And then my noses chapter am I lifted, Chapman knows Jeff.
Now imagine it's at the top and.
Everyone goes awesome.
Guilty cook, cook, cook cook. Yup. That's me, dude.
McConnell has lost his mind do it. His Instagram is just,
absolutely in charge. Matthew McConaughey.
Instagram is saying charge, bro.
Let's just go look at some of his stuff, man. He makes Garth Brooks look like a
twin. This guy.
Christmas happy holiday season. Um, as we approach Christmas.
So I'm going to have it back home with my family, my brother and my mother.
So someone asked me today like, Oh, so from when to, when do you open presents?
Is it one hour from like eight to 9:00 AM, 10 to 11:00 AM.
And I was reminded of, since my mother's going to be there,
we're probably going over in present from 9:00 AM.
Till about 6:00 PM would be a full work day.
My mother demands that everyone open one precedent
at a time and everyone else watch and Ooh, and ah,
and guess what it is and celebrate that person's gift the problem with that
family at least eight or more.
And you're opening one at a time and everyone's watching somebody opened that
gift and then somebody doesn't want to tear the wrapping paper.
So they open it up real slow right here. It could be a nine hour day.
Wish me luck. Hope you get good presents too.
Oh, killing dude. Absolutely murdering open mic.
That would be an open mic joke. And Matthew McConaughey just killed it.
And guess if he's wearing a blue suit with a blue vest under it
and a blue undershirt with a white color dude,
guess if that is true and if you guess yes, you'd be right, dude.
It is so, it is so
Texan and also Connecticut to wear a blue button down with a white collar.
It is so unbelievable.
Matthew McConaughey. I'm telling you,
I can't wait until I'm this kind of famous
and I will be dude, just so I can do these kinds of things,
bro. Now the problem is, you know,
when he does the real let's just look at his Instagram, everything.
He's just so great, man, by the way, big, phenomenal actor,
like straight up busting his balls, but the best just real good.
And if anyone says he's not good, eat a Dick now,
does he dress like a Superman villain? Yes.
Always to look at this green jacket, he has an Instagram with the green tone,
like bro, I got to get a turtleneck, man.
I swear I put on a turtleneck the other day and, and everyone went,
Oh, I didn't buy it because it was.
Bro. I put on a turtleneck.
Uh, two grand,
it was two grand and I go like this K not going to buy this.
Wow. There's a picture of Matthew McConaughey on his Instagram with Matthew
McConaughey and, and, and uh, what's it Woody Harrelson in, uh,
in a Lake. Of course there is
one thing's for sure.
Matthew McConaughey has never a guy he's had sex with 40 women and that's,
it could have had sex with way more, but he's just,
it's just not the kind of guy. I'm just not the kind of style I do
always rolling a bugger to when he's talking one time when I
was in my, in my, when I was in high school,
my girlfriend broke up with me and broke my heart.
And then she started dating a Mormon guy and sh and she said he reminded her of
Matthew McConaughey and ever since then, I think about that all the time.
And it's all good. So anyway, it's all good. Now did she say,
cause his voice sounded like warm molasses and that's such a stupid thing to say
for a 18 year old. Yes. Is it all right? It is now. Was it.
A few years now?
The problem is not a problem, man.
20.
Getting a blow job in the beginning of the movie.
If you're watching it in the beginning of, he goes like this 2020,
getting sucked and doesn't show the, it doesn't show his waste.
Cause he's getting sucked.
Hello? Well, 2019 was.
Always shot. Every Instagram video he's ever done twice.
He did it once and he goes, nah, I don't like that one. Let's try it again.
And then did it. And then was like, yeah, that's fine.
And he always thought I could do a better, but what am I going to keep doing it?
He thought, every time
I know this dude, this is the important in life, man.
This is the important in life. It's not what the warrant it ran.
It's not the.
You know, I mean the Australia fires are pretty important,
but this is the important, dude.
We don't really know what's going on out there. We don't know.
Do you really know if we should be at war with Iran or not? Do you really know?
You got Fox news saying one thing you got CNN saying the other thing,
but you got me telling you.
I know for a fact just by looking at it that Matthew McConaughey only films,
Instagram videos twice.
That's the we need to know.
Let's start there, dude.
[inaudible] set it on Instagram.
Dude. Let's watch it again. The beginning of it.
What's that about? Well,
2019 was a lot cooler as you
did.
I'm looking at 2020 to be a lot cooler because we do
running for office, running for office. Dude.
Did it twice. Added that the second time. I know how to make it pop.
Did that? See you there, dude. Wow. See you.
There is so something Matthew McConaughey would say at the end,
instead of seeing next year, he doesn't like, I don't like it's kind of corny.
We say see you next year. I say, see there, there you see there.
That's kind of one of my things. If 2019 was be a lot cooler.
If you did
220 was a lot cooler of luck cooler. He did it.
A lot of cooler coolers get our coolers 2020,
but Bayer coolers put beer in our cooler
and then somebody just comments. My platonic love heart eyes.
K what's going on? You brain broken dude. So many people's brains are broken.
It's unbelievable.
It's unbelievable that people's brains are broken for real.
Uh, uh, what's Tom Hanks, his son Chet,
Chet, Hanks, Chet Hanks.
Did you see what he said at some Bomba clot?
Hmm. Well, uh, what happened? Whitney's sent this to me. Hold on.
Where is it? Why? Why is Tom [inaudible] chat? Speaking
Patois. Cool. It's French. Um.
Oh my God. We got big, massive it's cowboy chapter.
Now coming straight from that golden globe
wrote that the accent say golden Globes,
like golden gloves as the whitest thing ever.
Golden Globes
pick up the whole nylon massive it's
coming straight from that golden globe.
Big up to the whole Island. He says, I think
we got the whole Island massive it's cowboy chapter.
Now coming straight from that golden globe.
Absolutely saying nothing. And even people from Patois people,
it was a big part to are like this. That was why Tom Hanks was making that face.
It was just delayed by the way, at the golden gloves when he was like,
cause he, cause he just saw his son on Twitter. Go.
[Inaudible] people on the movie, on the area
we got missed on standbys day movie on the area. Snored. This informer
informer. Yes. No
[inaudible] your dad's Tom Hanks
dude. Oh he does another one. Oh, I didn't know.
Oh, more intimate. Oh, I didn't know. Why is he doing this
then? We're at the, King's done. Wake up this morning.
Let me see the pain tunnel. Intimate gone. Mad. Respect your domino,
miss old fall. But I got, or.
I didn't know was gonna be that sexy dude.
Set it on the way out of smoothie King. Not even joking,
walking out a smoothie King, wake up. Nobody has ever said
come out.
Yo you with them.
I came at a smoothie gig. Yo,
we got dude. I like how he came a little quiet at smoothie King. He was like,
I know people don't do this normally,
but we got bought the smoothie King Island. Massive.
Wow.
Uh, somebody said blame Drake. Wow. That's funny dude.
Why does he speak in on it? Why is he speaking on that? Also?
How old is this guy? Shouldn't he be older?
I've been sitting him this age for a long time. Hmm.
He's only 29. Huh? Wow. He has music. Right?
Well that's cool man. Oh man. You know what? If my son grows up to be like that,
I'm going to do that with him.
I'm going to be like this. That's right. Big, big. Let's go. What do you want?
Huh? You want to go to jumbo? Maria?
We going to jumbo rebuilt my son here for John buddy.
Tommy Ireland. [inaudible]
[inaudible] that's why?
What happened when [inaudible], when [inaudible]
that's what happened up here in diarrhea. In the boxes.
I got my that's where I still wearing the, I
didn't stay outside while I was on while I was in kindergarten. Yup.
So I was scared of, he said he was going to wait for me in case I got scared.
He left the [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] when we fire truck.
Well, they've been, excuse me. I'm a little cranky misdemeanor time wheels.
My fire truck. [inaudible]
you too. Wow, dude.
Love it.
Wow. Chet hacks, dude.
He writes an Instagram officially blasted.
Okay.
What does it take to be officially blasted dude, man, he got inked up. Huh?
Oh, I got to get officially blasted for real. I'm only partially blasted.
I got blasted on my [inaudible] and on my
big old the movie on the area around here,
but I needed to get officially blasted.
I just need to get the Batman and Signia on my chest and just get officially
blasted Patois, put toys, you know,
that's what I said. Woopsie.
So racist.
Man. I love it, dude.
It's 2020, man. It is 2020. Yeah.
How much has Matthew McConaughey sort of got going to be like this 2020 man.
Funny thing about that is I got 2020 vision. Yeah,
I got 20. That's my hot, my eyesight for,
for the future for 2020 is exactly what year it is. 2020 vision.
Let's do it again. Then he does it again. He says that's it.
I don't do it again.